the people I really admired were the
people that like didn't mystify acting
too much who were just able to like come
to set and do it Elder Thon David thulis
Gary Alman Michael gaman they're all
people that can be very normal and
chatting away and then can just turn it
on on action they're people that Elda
was one of the people that I always just
looked at and went like you're so good
and it's so effortless Michael Gamin
could do that to a frustrating degree he
learned that he could as when I was a
teenager like he could make me laugh
very very easily make me laugh like
right up until the word action at which
point I was pretty much unable to
recover and he could just like Snap into
a performance with just like inherent
gravitas and charm forgive my mors
Harry I'm an old man